ladies and gentlemen coming out of
retirement the first of probably many
times to review Twilight Breaking Dawn
Part two three
well first of all the applause and
everything else you had there it's very
it's not deserved um okay so uh show of
hands how many people have seen this
movie yeah you do not deserve to be in
the same room as normal bread breathing
people okay sorry that that was a little
harsh oh so so hot just moving this
would be a little um bad how do I talk
about this movie well maybe like a snack
I'm getting ahead of myself here timing
for that okay so um anyone here have
seen the other Twilight movies okay okay
okay again jumping the gun
oh okay so for those of you who are 40
of them fortunate enough not to
experience uh the first what we have for
Twilight movies and now we have part 4
part 2 point 3 we have a film where
Bella is now a vampire and emotionless
beast not much of a transition but the
great thing about it is now that Bella
has become this creature sucking type
boy acts of the night that means that
everyone else takes so excited that they
want to move at the speed of light every
chance they get and I'm not just like
okay like when they're fighting in a
vampire wants to go fancy
that's it do it you're a vampire use
your right but like she wants to get a
book and suddenly it's like Benny Hill
other things it's a book it's a suit
like a fucking Roadrunner
I don't know why what I any if she
checks her phone is like a 50 why why
and everybody does this and there's no
way to make it so this is not funny it's
hilarious every single time she goes
through whatever it should be other time
I want to say I feed and that Apache
Mountain on medical but no that would be
prejudiced against Mexican people and
Lord knows we have a bit prejudice
enough against the vampire genre so okay
she has given birth to a beautiful CG
baby ionising kidding this film is so
cheap they couldn't get a baby maybe the
baby was asking for too much money I
don't know but you have this thing
that's making baby geniuses to look like
Gollum from or the Rings it really looks
like somebody just took the label from
baby food of the baby going like this
and just to move his mouth that's that's
the baby and yet somehow it still almost
more than Bella I don't have a fan this
but okay as we all know the baby's
future husband Jacob Oh miss that part
okay let me explain Jacob sees this baby
gets a wolf the owner says hey you know
what in hopefully 18 years I bet you'll
be hot and I just might want to do that
a nice bit of tails considering I really
do have a tail at times so okay yeah the
baby grows up pretty fast and I don't
mean like you know oh
so fast no I mean within a day she's
like seven and you're saving yourself oh
well how many days or years or month or
whatever it went by for that but they
don't tell us for all we know literally
they have a dissolve of the baby
somehow standing up to be measure ah the
toddler and then the seven-year-old just
dissolving and you know what maybe it
was real time we don't know is
definitely Myers made up so much shit
about Twilight and vampires and stuff
like that I avoid anything if you said
that vampires can only shoot wet out of
their arms and swing around like
spider-man you know what that will be
awesome eventually see that movie you
know what just anything outside a
sparkling My Little Pony sparkly want
some pasta again get it myself okay so
we got a shake-up the future husband to
be two fellas daughter and we have
Edward who still can't emote out of a
paper bag
in fact this uh duct tape here has much
more emotion at Edward ever we'll see
you believe to hit the ground which is
much more than anything and whatever
done and they're concerned because one
of their cousins sees the little
seven-year-old prodigy the Rosemary's
Baby if you will who is walking around
and said I don't recognize her I'm gonna
go tell the Big Pun legal channels or
whatever they are okay so she goes and
does that and of course Bella
sees that because it sees it and says to
herself oh wait a minute this is back
and she's gonna say that and they're
gonna think she's a violation gonna come
down and kill her and they're preparing
this army and they're getting all the
other vampire brethren people's Barclays
together and they're like oh we have to
fight my fight you know what here's an
idea you have cell phones she's your
cousin you probably know her number they
just give her a little con to feel okay
it's cool it's totally cool it's my kid
yeah no Imagi live birth well yeah we
Sparkle to just go in it and you know
what we could avoid it we can avoid this
whole big
that'll think of all the big panel oh
let me tell you will concentrate
cracking to that don't you
color you've read the boy down okay
those who read the book you know what's
coming and you know this is justified
okay so you have a fella
and you know the little C G seven year
old baby person
oh they see G the seven year old until
like a hot you know twenty year old in a
future flashback yeah wasn't that's a
perfect spring come true Jacobs probably
and so then they go and they tell this
guy who I swear is like an anorexic
version of Andy Serkis who loves to
overact even more than Andy Serkis I
mean I got Andy Serkis could do the
column voice and he wouldn't be he still
more credible than this guy I mean this
guy here is that there's you know this
immaculate birthdays just like oh and
we'll talk supposed to do that was some
computer models in the movie okay and
then they had this really cool thing
where they get all the vampires from all
across the world to see the Immaculate
bitch and she touches people with her
hand and apparently that convinces them
oh it's female Jesus awesome and anybody
watches her it's like okay we're on her
side awesome great uh the only downside
is that for whatever reason the Brethren
don't get this news even though they're
aware of everything that's going out I
think I'm here this little thing hey
know that person we're trying to kill
everybody saying that she's you know the
real deal are very awesome
we're vampires we Sparkle we look like
Gollum and overact like bad okay
so we get to okay let me just think
there's a tag on this guy I just want to
build up properly the ending of it all
let's talk about the father
yeah but the father would have only two
likable characters in the entire movie
the other being Jacob over he turn
pedophile was actually really nice and
really smart always going along with
everything until he hears that Bella
might be dead
well that kind of sucks yeah daughter
only daughter day you know what those
Bella I'd be in the same boat the more I
think about it but anyway so you got him
there chopping wood Jacob goes shows
he's a friggin werewolf
you know same reaction is Bella and goes
in Bella totally really not to tell her
dad that she's alive just let him
believe that she's dead it just really
mad at Jacob when she you know when he
goes and tells her father that he's
actually you know that she's actually
alive and kicking and screaming well not
kicking screaming because I would allow
emotion but that she is in fact Angela
gets mad at him of course Edwards
backing her on that because you know
he's her bitch um so he goes and you
know listen says what's going on
that boys a werewolf and she says don't
ask questions he says okay what just
goes with it is just totally fine I
think it may be the occasional question
why is he a werewolf I don't know and I
and and I say to myself you know this is
a loving family anything like a loving
family where you know they actually care
about each other what to get you to care
for the little Satan spawn that's
pulling these two boys around with their
LEGO pieces and they're just part of her
little Barbie franchise I gotta make
that back you know makes sense that be
using him as like these Barbie you know
toys like she is that she would make
them Sparkle how do you think Stephenie
Meyer it says I think there really is a
balance wadis you put the story together
she's just trying to show all those
people in high school that you know that
really overweight ugly person that was
really
more than everybody laughing overlapping
the vampire game and yo really getting
into him so just like just like how
would you I'm gonna sell my soul let's
say to make this so I should actually
have you on because I was gonna read it
my different arenas not gonna make any
we're gonna make this sword stuff
instead off it's gonna simmer wait to
answer Dhamma that even can't be
dissipated as a never have any I'm
giving the myself let's let's talk about
the climax not the one you're thinking
now went wait for Jacob in the baby who
I don't know what this panel is rated so
okay we got this great big build this is
the only moment in the Twilight movie
that's kind of cool
you have all the vampire Brethren's all
those people from Eyes Wide Shut in the
cloaks they're lined up ready to march
across the ice cuz the ice does a break
here apparently and all the vampires and
werewolves are on the other side and
they line up and they're there they're
about to have their big loaded arrays
battle and stuff like that and they look
at racing we want to kill the child and
the Bella's like but to error note screw
you cuz if it's your heads getting
chopped off but we can say a few because
never looking already what he's up with
the MPAA okay so they go and they say
this child is not going to be dangerous
he's gonna be fine she really is
immaculate blah blah blah so everything
appears to be okay but the golem leader
there looks it over and he looks at the
child as as Oh
let me see who you it's not as perverted
as it is I don't know but by the line he
goes are she touches his face and
suddenly he sees that everything they
said is true
great so there's no problem right well
he decides he may want to be a dick for
no reason except
he may want to be a dick so he goes and
this uh watching talents the woman who
can see into the future at times when
it's convenient for the plot she comes
up and she goes over to the column
vampire let lets him you know touch her
hand because that allows him to see into
the future can they both see into the
future I don't know how it works but
England he sees that she says oh you're
not going to change your mind the matter
what happened he fucking Bob goes crazy
all the vampire costume show they go
running towards the vampires and
werewolf all the way over on a towards
the other and I swear to god damn god
damn that these things are ripping hands
off this is why because suddenly Fayette
plans with like the Planeteers and they
can do fire with earth water not hard
because they've actually required in the
soul so they get down okay
Oh brown is breaking it's like a fucking
earthquake
everything is calling vampires
werewolves polygons of like is this
swine a reward of a ridge what the hell
is this it's unbelievable Bella and
Edward look at each other in a legit
badass moment they look at that Gollum
vampire and they say you're going down
they rushed towards him but Edward
finally uses Bella for what she should
be a human shit why
knocked into the ground she she got
chickens on his head every tackles head
like a football player
they read the cupcake read by her hand
off wrong to the ground
they're not just burning alive everybody
is falling to their grave heads are
flying
blood everywhere the commanding headless
all this incredible stuff
the most awesome holy goddamn it has you
would believe what you just witnessed
turns out it was all a dream
I would say that you're all overreacting
because this is just a movie except that
every goddamn person in that theater
even the Twilight fans had the exact
same goddamn reaction that you have
look at the screen they work what they
don't even give the explanation they go
what it's like an automatic you know
what's gonna get you go out you see
bullshit okay you don't know and they
okay
the German is pushing it cuz dream would
actually mean you don't it'd be some
credibility no it was the vision that
the Alice chick who can see into the
future is giving the creepy gullible
vampire guy to see what would happen to
him if he attacked her he says well shit
that sucked by and they head out so
after all the Twilight movies all the
bullshit two movies to buy it up
actually telling us the moral of the
story the moral of the story is if you
sacrifice nothing do nothing play the
boy toys life boy toys you can live
happily ever after
as the blood sucking demon that you are
fuck you Stephenie Meyer's
so what did I think of this movie
I didn't like it very much it had some
chances maybe becoming something at the
end it's just for epic stupidity but
instead what we have is one of the
stupidest worst franchises that has ever
existed in mankind so put me back to the
plot I'm gonna stash the trick can I
remember it so you don't have to